now to a devastating weekend of extreme
weather here in the south at least 26
people were killed by a tornado in
Western Mississippi just one of a series
of storms that have been hammering the
region there President Biden has
declared a major disaster in the area
but this system is not done yet Omar via
Franca is in a place called Rolling Fork
Mississippi Omar good morning to you
what are you seeing there well we can
see right there how bad it is wow good
morning
yeah good good morning the tornado that
hit here had wind speeds of up to 170
miles per hour and let me show you what
that kind of power can do to a building
it's almost apocalyptic I mean the roof
of this home was ripped off the walls
knocked down cars and trucks were tossed
around like they were toys everything
around us was destroyed by the storm
tornadoes lightning and hail are tearing
through the South
early Sunday multiple Twisters were
reported in Georgia and overnight
intense storms brought heavy rains and
flooding but it was Friday's tornado in
Mississippi that decimated the area and
left more than 25 people dead I was
aware that the tunnel was was could be
in the forecast but I was not aware that
it was coming Gail Barfield and her
husband Howard heard on TV they had two
minutes to take cover when the tornado
hit a wall crashed onto the closet
trapping Gail it took a pickup truck to
eventually free her how are you still
here God
you believe God saved you
know
later that day her husband suffered a
heart attack he's now recovering in the
hospital I've never been through nothing
like that and I didn't know that it
could be so devastating the destruction
is widespread and in every direction
with at least 2 000 homes damaged or
destroyed from Friday's tornado Chapel
of the Cross Church is usually packed
with parishioners on Sunday morning this
week volunteers were cleaning up the
rubble in the sanctuary some of these
our parishioners grew up in this church
never knew any other Church in their
life
and of course they're very upset but
among the ruins stands a miracle so you
you just had this made it was installed
two weeks ago and then this happens but
yet it is untouched untouched one
stained glass window without a single
scratch your grandma has been a member
for decades decades she's probably never
missed a Sunday the artwork is dedicated
to Francis Mitchell's grandmother when
you saw it
what did you think
burst into tears when I rounded the
corner and saw it
I don't know
let me give you another example of the
power of this storm this car here was
destroyed the homeowner lives here her
husband's truck is about a hundred yards
away it was rolled that far away and
it's now in a ditch but despite all this
damage people here are telling us they
want to rebuild they want to stay here